Every day is magical.
At Disney's Animal Kingdom theme park.
But for Mac, the African bull elephant
today is once in a lifetime.
So today is Mac's 40th birthday.
So we are getting together
a little birthday party for him.
We have a birthday
cake made by our animal nutrition center.
I like his to see his eyes saying,
Oh yeah, I see potato ice queen.
Good boy, Mac. Mom.
No time to waste.
Mac loves the party.
The theme is St Patrick's Day.
What are you planning on
using the carrots for, then?
I'm going to make little gold
inside of his pot of gold.
So use the watermelon for that.
Oh, very cool.
The boy,
another favorite, frozen fruit treats.
So I'm going to be making
these ice treats here
and trying to coordinate with the rainbow
that we're doing with the elephant team.
We're going to do
sweet potatoes and carrots in one layer
for orange apples in the other.
For red blueberries or blue.
I'll be doing celery for green.
And then one of my favorites is bananas.
All right, Mac. Going, boy.
It's going to be delicious.
Oh, yeah.
Nailed it.
You guys ready? Ready? Ready. Let's go.
Saint Patrick himself
would approve of this spread
mostly.
Hello, Mac.
It's your big birthday celebration.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I'm so excited.
Here he comes.
Mac has a really big personality.
He's just really fun to work with.
As he's getting older,
you can see that he is aging.
Is a distinguished older gentleman.
He definitely still has what it takes
to keep up with our younger elephants.
Keep going.
You all this other stuff.
There's so much more.
Oh, yeah.
There you go.
Oh, happy birthday.
Oh, look, there's watermelon.
He. He deserve that pot of gold.
He says,
let me just knock these carrots off.
I don't need those.
I don't need the healthy.
That's not necessary.
Oh, go. Oh.
Water. The water.
On. I like going to eat it.
And he closed his eyes.
Yes. You so good.
What a great birthday celebration.
Ooh, that's a big piece.
Oh, he ate it.
Oh, brain freeze.